[Music]
well you want it you got it
let's see if this Ultimate Edition makes
this movie better in any way is it
shorter it is not shorter ah welcome to
the party gentleman loan just so you
know there's still gonna be some absurd
leaps and logic unexplained coincidences
and continued overacting in this edition
but glad you're here we've made it to
our first difference in this movie where
we get to see Bruce's mom's face a lot
better in one shot thank God the shot
was restored so that the redundant
Bruce's parents get murdered scene could
confirm that this asshole is about to
shoot her in the chin luckily Bruce
Wayne is here to make sure this one
easily seen kid gets back into the buddy
line
The Ultimate Edition shows us the school
children to explain that there was a
field trip which is why there's a random
girl standing in the middle of a
dangerous building collapse later but
there are two teachers here one at the
beginning and one at the end of the line
and they can't do a simple headcount yes
things are chaotic but apparently they
prescribe to the Child Left Behind
program Africana taste the feeling you
know what hereon always says were on
assignment together not a goddamn thing
I like hearin so far Jimmy Olsen simply
introduced himself and asked how she
landed this interview he hasn't been a
jackass or insulted Lois in any way but
here he is getting cut out of the movie
before Warner Brothers gets a chance to
do it themselves
your fixer said that the general lapew
photos this line is included in case you
needed more evidence that the bad guys
are even bigger assholes when they later
smash Jimmy's camera they did not tell
me the interview was with a lady man
what's up with this fucking fixer does
he communicate anything with anyone he
must be a random mechanic that everyone
just assumes can arrange complex
international media encounters with
rebel killers who basically throwing
stuff I saw what I had tonight by this
point in the theatrical release Jimmy's
camera is already smashed watch these
two movies side-by-side and you go back
in time why the fuck what a clandestine
Drecker beacon beep this loudly or at
all stand down as an order how do you go
from a vapid military drama to an
oversea GI doomsday in three hours or
less stick around the ultimate edition
clears the air on whether or not the
stood for dudes during this gunfight is
there even anybody in this tank it's
just a park tank
right maybe it's sabotage I have no clue
but explosions you are clear to engage
you know if Superman had arrived a bit
earlier and just saved Lois and the CIA
went ahead and blew the hell out of the
village there wouldn't be any reason for
the Senate panel to investigate Superman
so Lex is extremely lucky here with the
sequence of events which is really this
whole movie also
talk about Lex's plan he somehow knows
Louis is going to interview an African
warlord knows the CIA is involved
somehow inserts his own men into the
situation knows that Superman will show
up knows that he can implicate Superman
when things go wrong if he was this
smart he should have won already
drone the Superman yeah the CIA was
about to bomb this entire village I
assume at least one person saw the
missile headed there and heard the
gunshots beforehand but everybody can
blame him Supes for whatever reason they
should be thanking him for saving
everyone else's life Jesus is fuckin
movie ultimate edition of moody contains
ultimate edition of Amy Adams acting
solely through her face he came down
then came fire now it makes a lot more
sense
Superman is being accused of burning all
those bodies which we didn't see in the
theatrical release we're still not
removing us in because they still
somehow find a way to blame Superman
based on one person's testimony a person
they never vet once metropolis state
also more exciting football action as
can only be brought to you by the
ultimate edition yep it's all I ever
hear about Gotham City their football
fandom erupts in violence worse than
vancouver after hockey loss zack snyder
drops a reference to another comic book
movie that he honest to god this cop
climbs more stairs in this version can't
make this stuff so this guy is still
running an underground sex trade
organization right do we give it what
happens to him more blood more wine more
precoital looks also our rated ultimate
edition still gives us a pg-13 naked
Lois Lane is rich old ladies then if I
was very cute you know write checks for
Lex I know this extended scene is to
fill some backstory about Lex's
relationship with his father but it
really only gives us a few more seconds
to be disappointed in Jesse Eisenberg's
performance look him in his eye and ask
him how he decides which life's count it
makes way more sense for Clark to be
seeing something that actually matters
to his story rather than some nonsense
about Batman branding people so you
should hate him like the theatrical
release dip still if you watch these two
versions they made Clark react the same
way to Batman's branding as they did to
this lady's testimony about the stuff he
allegedly did the cake is a lie what was
the direction here Henry we're gonna
show something on the TV you just stand
there and emote underdog dreams dashed
ten yards between Gotham and glory
wait the only football game that was
added to this edition was the blowout
when metropolis state beat Gotham City's
64 to nothing how is that ten yards away
from anything she
and she's been gone in fact if she's
smart and she got out of this city how
long has it been since the Nairobi scene
we just saw in Louis getting back
yesterday but the woman from the village
has had time to say goodbye to her
village after the Americans left and the
government attack and she's had time to
move to the US appear in a Senate
hearing in DC rent an apartment then
move out I just up a winning lottery
ticket for an unnecessary bat sketch
benefit for the library of Metropolis
someone on the committee requested that
Clark Kent cover it and newspapers give
stories to reporters based on the
requests of random people beside doesn't
he have football to cover also assuming
Lex is the one that invited Clark how
the does he already know that Clark is
Superman there may be some logical
explanation but it's in neither of the
cuts of this movie so that fake-ass
knowledge no bourbon Kentucky girl like
yourself even though we got plenty of
evidence the senator is from Kentucky
this edition which is ultimate by the
way requires this clumsy exchange to
drive it home maybe one day that'll come
back if I just keep everything the same
hmm and a silly movie makes a ham-fisted
attempt to explain that Lex has daddy
issues far but see that past Rafi is
that Clark asked this question even
though we now know he spent extra time
investigating in Gotham where Bruce
Wayne is ridiculously super famous we
said it before we even knew that so now
let's double it good people living in
fear and the bullshit theatrical release
you didn't get this Ben Affleck smirk he
bulled theatrical release never seen a
model like this Jena Malone is here to
deliver a line that Louis repeats later
in the theatrical cut experts at the
Pentagon can't ID it and is thus
adorably unnecessary gotta ask why even
bother casting her in this for two
scenes sure you don't know that it's
gonna get cut out but it's two scenes
and it's not like everybody's looking
out for a Jena Malone cameo this makes
way more sense in the Ultimate Edition
Batman's been branding lots of criminals
whereas in the theatrical release he
branded one guy that everybody decided
to jump to conclusions that the bat
brand was a death sentence in prison so
we'll take us in off because of this
version but the theatrical version still
is clearly becomes too this movie tries
to sneak in another watchman reference
by speeding past it but I drink your
Easter Egg movie or something like that
what the do you want seriously one
f-bomb you could have totally given a
fuck in a pg-13 cut I can't even piss
stand-in out well at least the
screenwriters got to throw in some more
pissed dialogue you'll take care
good so wait is this version of the
movie saying that this guy is ordering
people with the bat brands to be killed
in prison for walking reason but Batman
began branding people did he
coordinators efforts with this dude who
works for Lex I just don't know why that
brand puts you at the top of the list
for shipping that's all oh no some dick
had died let me decide from the red and
blue costume and I don't know fact that
he has one third of the USA's initials
on his chest
I like Jon Stewart but does that mean
one third of the USA's initials who
gives it it's the sword of Alexander
ultimate cut gives us more footage of a
description of a fake artifact I applaud
the theatrical edition for cutting the
scene down by adding three more to this
bloated position
some people say this isn't a dream
sequence because it doesn't show Bruce
falling asleep but there is no
indication whatsoever that these are
potentially real events and he's shown
waking up after that scene and the flash
scene any reasoning like that after the
fact is just excusing this silly attempt
of putting out of place fanboy
wish-fulfillment into a completely
different movie even if it's not a dream
sequence it's basically that Thor
nonsense from age of Ultron so it's
simplest no the mark all over cards
don't care that's the judge yeah but is
he working with the bad guys remember
it's the guy who works for Lex who's
commissioning these bat brand Shang
Kings in prison what is the origin story
of the bat bran becoming an instant
death sentence what does it supposedly
mean it's simple to make Batman seem
like a morally weaker superhero but has
no foundation for becoming a thing hey
Batman you don't want to double-cross
your prisoner killing partner do you so
far the only interesting differences
between these two versions are the
expanded CIA attack at the beginning the
different ordering of scenes and Clark's
better understanding of the bat Brants
even though technically they still don't
make sense in the store this right here
isn't one of those scenes does this
woman live in Nairobi or not
how is she a credible witness during
that CIA thing at the beginning of this
movie I don't know if they ever explain
why she looks like she's lived in the
greater Gotham metropolis San Jose area
her whole life also we're still on this
si story that no one cares about but how
could they know that he'd show up in
they still don't explain this in this
version Louis again cuts herself off as
if she's just realized Superman is drawn
to my blood like Edward to Bella in
Twilight but they never make that plain
anywhere
those are ensnared
for Superman oh no it needs to run now
Lois Lane who is supposedly a great
reporter thinks this is a story you can
just run without proof she's been using
committee is this puppet theater okay
then why not call the meeting off you
know Lex has been several steps ahead of
you and you know how dangerous he is
you see him right there I'm sure nobody
saw that and subways have zero cameras
you can get away with anything down
there another scene where Supes is
moving extremely slowly relative to his
abilities is this really the right place
to take your sweet-ass time
ultimate edition now with a hundred
percent more alfrid manual labor also
after that Capitol building explosion I
really wondered what alfred thought
about all this now my wish is granted
there was a sin before about not seeing
Batman breaking Alec's Court now that we
get a brief glimpse of how awesome that
break-in was I'm adding 10 more more
things going into things more sweaty
workouts Alexander Luthor your security
override has been accepted in the
theatrical release I just assumed they
cut out the part where the ship decided
to accept Luthor's override but the
addition of ultimate no still doesn't
explain it to completely mess bhaisaab
why is Clark walking exactly can he just
fly at the top of the mountain is he
trying to prove something burning
calories inside of the chair is like a
celeb we didn't send the fact that Supes
didn't see the bond in the first
go-around but since this edition finally
actually explained something helpful
I'll remove one sit still simple sir
phones the Hoff Wayne this line was cut
for time one of the advantages the
Ultimate Edition has over the theatrical
release is more Nancy Grace and more the
Lois kidnapping that's the shot in the
arm this movie needs again this movie
does nothing to explain some of the
biggest questions of the movie how
Superman knows when Lois is in danger no
matter where he is in the world Lex
knows the identities of Superman and
Batman how Lex knows how to operate the
Kryptonian ships computer functions
stuff I think an extra 30 minutes is
more than enough to explain especially
since most of the additions in this
movie have wasted time on extra lines
more violence and that cop climbing the
stairs
it also doesn't explain this so the rest
of the movie either guys not making this
up but this movie adds 12 extra seconds
to its runtime so we can see this
asshole walk farther more like Ultimate
Edition am i right
there is more Batman V Superman in this
Batman V Superman but it's stuff like
this he didn't get enough suddenly
fruitless punching in the other version
now here's even more suddenly fruitless
punching wha I don't think we've given
enough since for the scene like in
2046 when we're all long dead from the
Martian volcanoes sacrifice the
electrons in the air will sense the need
to sin this idea that made it past
someone's brain and on to a screenplay
and then pass multiple other brain
were actually got filmed edited and
released to the public sir your office
no sir
you don't this version touches more on
the romantic relationship between Bruce
and Alfred an area where no other Batman
movie has dared to tread
we're moving once in for the obvious
homosexual relationship that this movie
makes no big deal about the way it
should be
or Batman kicking ass and the best scene
is always a good thing but this mph has
me befuddled I haven't seen one thing in
this movie that would make it aren't
rated for violence there's no way this
is worse than your average pg-13 movie I
don't hate the center I hate the sin Lex
Luthor's philosophy is too dangerously
close to our own ubi does explain what
happened to Martha after Batman saves
her which is good because I was
beginning to think the Batman made her
walk home if anything this version
raises more questions as to why certain
things are cut and why certain ones are
not here's a shot of Perry looking out a
window that saves four seconds when you
cut it
I mean someone actually said we need to
lose this the brass needs an extra four
seconds guys
this probably got cut because it looks
stupidest while we were dumbfounded that
Superman didn't just throw the crypto
sphere instead of flying directly into
doomsday I'm even more dumbfounded now
that the spear didn't weaken Superman
enough to the point where he
crash-landed before being able to do
that more Superman faked death morning
oh this explains Lex Luthor's he is
hungry moment well we'll remove a sin I
guess why did they cut this still even
after he sets up the Batman fight then
unleashes doomsday Lex has time to
interact with an even badder batty
forget arresting this asshole just take
him out now Chili's ready what Kennedy's
dead food borne the lowest staring at
the ceiling scene
stays in seriously watch the theatrical
version against this version side by
side and the bagpipes start playing row
row row your boat they said it's all
taken care of by home animist owner
Bruce paid for the funeral pretty badass
civilization on the way matters down
looking how just show me any moment in
either of these two editions when Lex
figures this out apparently his
superpower is to just casually know
everyone's secret identity I refer you
to transfer Arkham Asylum in Cabo
no one's ever escaped it so it's a
perfect place to put you also great now
he can interact with the other super
villains for the convenience of this
universe
wait a minute is this burial still going
on didn't we see Bruce here in Kansas
when they dropped off the coffin then he
went to tell Lex Luthor what's what and
now Louis is still here
they come back
and I got a boat let's say
[Music]
knock down boy tell me you ever dance
with the devil in the pale light I never
really chopped wood before but certainly
looks like fun then what better way to
make your grand entrance on the streets
of Agrabah than riding your very own
brown camel watch out they spit you
almost took my face off I'd like to take
his his face oh and here you sit
thinking well Ricky Bobby is not a
thinker Ricky Bobby is a driver night of
the fight you may feel a slight sting
that's prime fuck much pride
[Music]